qui le défend
madame
assassy madame il est défendu
[Musique]
il est défendu
il est
[Musique]
on se calme comme dirait l'autre ça va
bien se passer vous inquiétez pas
donc nous considérons que l'expression
dette au sens de maastrichtant à
invisibiliser le caractère contraignant
d'un traité européen en l'occurrence
celui de Maastricht qui parlent la
coordination de politique économique
c'est-à-dire l'article 121 et la formule
lapidaire de l'artiste 126 je cite les
États membres évitent les déficits
excessives consacrent le jou des
institutions européennes à l'instar des
décisions nationales en matière de
dépenses publiques
je vous l'ai dit ça va bien se passer
donc cette réforme des retraites
il convient de la rappeler et de le
rappeler émane d'une volonté européenne
de réduction de la dépense publique dont
c'est amendement permet de ne pas
omettre la Genèse Walty le sens de cet
amendement
[Musique]